I believe in normal on the top I keep it
dark you get it all shaved off me yeah
hell no I'm going to give you a high top
faint why don't you go girl like me in
the middle
cuz it's my show me hi I'm gqueues Marc
Anthony green by day I'm a writer for
the magazine and by night when I'm not
rolling Chris Brown on Twitter I'm
learning how to play the harmonica I'm
hanging out at our barbershop at
Barclays Center getting haircuts and
talking with interesting people
hopefully they don't cut my hair too bad
people are so excited about your show
coming back myself included
what can we expect in the second season
I haven't seen it yet but I love the
script so far and seeing the first one I
only saw at the same time as everyone
else so we're nervous that you were
gonna suck yeah I was nervous because
I've never done you know was my first
time doing like a full big like
character and an arc and when I started
on the show I didn't know that I was
gonna like be around at all but I felt
pretty good about it now you and I we
went to high school together a lot of
people don't know that well I know
friends so I can ask you for a favor
yeah yeah it's Laura single I can page
her she she only has a pager she only
has a pager yeah yeah but I can page
you're into that you like a little bit
it's kind of that that old school do
people ask you about your leg all the
time yes well cuz a lot of times I beg
is your leg real is my fake leg real
right is my real leg real you know to me
like exactly that's deep that's like
some Plato [ __ ] right how would you
survive
a five-year big in prison I'd probably
make sure it's real quiet and some point
that comes here I look up to the biggest
guy and I get some like hard piece of
fruit like at their head like a whole
pineapple and I would smash it over his
head and it was all bloody like rub it
on my face and starts screaming I don't
think you can just like lay low you know
is there any career model or actor that
you're kind of chasing
yeah Matthew McConaughey in ten years
yeah that's like his acceptance speech
summer long Ashley who do I look - I
thought about and I had me in ten years
so I'm always chasing myself you're
chasing the same version he's chasing
exactly but the version that he is now
you're like I'm like I mean did he's
incredible he's the man okay you were a
magician I was a magician yeah how did
the ladies like that
ladies love magician Matt yeah Matt
chick that's what I said on my card
magic magic magicians at home do not
steal that name all right so let's do a
speed round I'm gonna ask you about
different celebrities now this is the
barbershop which means that you are
legally under oath to tell us how you
truly feel Miley Cyrus I think there's a
lot of overreaction to Miley Cyrus the
slut-shaming I don't know it takes power
away from women to do kind of what they
want to do Justin Bieber I feel bad for
him and I really do it's like it's
probably so complicated what he's gone
through and beyond understanding for the
vast majority of people I'm single yeah
I'll go on a date with you no doesn't
know that's not where we were going what
what dating advice do you have for me be
yourself and know that like the person
who's gonna be in love with you when you
fall head-over-heels in love yeah he's
the person that's gonna love all that
weird [ __ ] about you I was looking for
like pickup lines okay you're dropping
some serious heavy knowledge on me I
just was it's the same thing as when you
go in a person man find that pineapple
biggest guy in the bar smash it over his
head and now I do it rub the blown your
face and then they come running and then
they come run it yeah I think you're
trying to set me up
haha these guys are good yeah I mean
I've had I have the shape once before
isn't not quite as inclusive is there
can you do a trick for us I could do a
trick
here right hold us you're here for me Oh
Shh mind blown
thank you so much for coming my pleasure
ma'am best of luck with the show thank
you we're gonna be watching it is gonna
completely ruin a weekend however you
like to do it I will binge watch it out
it's like so sad
it's actually thank you very much let's
be good so that was me and Matt McGorry
from oranges new black make sure you
subscribe to the GQ channel and click
the little like thing at the bottom if
you liked it or if you didn't like it
still click the like thing will take
your sympathy lights see you next time
[Music]